i don't ski i used to ski i used to do
snowboarding i used to [ __ ] kill it
you didn't do it
i did all that yeah i did all that
i did i did all that i did snowboarding
i got this dude you know he didn't do it
don't sit here and agree with him
what am i going to lie about skiing for
i don't know if where'd you ski in new
jersey yes get in new jersey and it's a
lie and i also skied in utah
you didn't grow up skiing in utah that's
true that's true in new jersey and i
skied in utah no maybe you were a ski
mask in new jersey got into some
freaking crime bro there's no ski in
there
jersey
i'm on this side bro i skied in new
jersey i skied in utah we're at at red
shield
in new jersey did you ski in the middle
of the day
i skied in utah though yeah
i'm trying to think about how young i
was when i did this [ __ ] i remember our
[ __ ] nanny took us but that was
probably in utah
are you ready dude what we got rich bro
not growing up
whatever he had a nanny for the game
yeah after we got rich [ __ ] you i got
kidnapped two times you idiot that's
your fault bro his name was looking
around bro
you got [ __ ] kidnapped with a dump
truck like that bro you got [ __ ] you
got strength yeah but i didn't know at
the time nobody taught me anything oh
they were nice to you they tricked you
chris is privileged huh chris is
privileged you're rubbing your privilege
in our face i don't give a [ __ ]
oh yeah i forgot about it look at him
right there with his probably his nanny
right there having a good time
dude i wonder how old she is now
look at his freaking nanny oh what's
your name probably what was her name
peekaboo street
she look she i look [ __ ] i look uh
lanky there i gotta i don't know man
you put on some size yeah you look like
a vape i don't like [ __ ] where you got
it here's what i don't like here's what
i don't like
i don't like the stuff
where
you gotta
get all the gear yeah it's too much i
just that's why stand up is my favorite
[ __ ] you just show up there's no amps
and [ __ ] you don't have to bring a
guitar
doing [ __ ] though yeah but but if i got
to do it i'm just going to show up i
don't need to get the mask and the skis
and the [ __ ] you know plug and play i i
just i'm in dude i'm already learning i
don't agree with them
it's fine it's fine everybody's
different and i like that about you i
want you to [ __ ] like skiing if you
like skiing you don't go skiing that
much that's what i'm saying but you say
when i can
let's go a lot
i did sled recently
um i would like to ski more i'm going to
say that all right fair enough really
and i hope in the future that i do and
i'll wait i'm okay with wearing the
stuff the night before the day before i
like that but i like that i like that i
like that you break in your [ __ ] thank
you thank you i do personally like that
thank you yeah thank you and you
chill out man yeah chill the [ __ ] out
bro don't agree with him now i'm not i'm
agreeing with both of you different
times during different times depending
on what you're saying and that's how
it's supposed to be brendan always
agrees with you um bro he agrees with
you off screen sometimes off-screen
yeah yeah maybe
after after this show he'll be like i
kind of agree with what theo said
let's go king and the sting and the wing
got it full circle and put on the whole
team legendary trio bringing chris and
theo what you mean you know it's the
king and the sting and the wing
[Music]
you